[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week end vous le
savez comme tous les vendredis nous
revenons sur les moments forts de
l'actualité culture sports et loisirs
avec nous en plateau aujourd'hui mighty
goldman bonjour alors vous avez écrit
plusieurs livres et vous
plusieurs livres et vous venez nous
présenter votre dernière parution dont
il s'intitule merci blaise prix le voici
donc il est paru en novembre 2013
et vous les dédicacer ce week end à
elancourt malaurie en résumé ce livre
ont rapidement donc c'est une succession
de nouvelles qui ont pour thème commun
la séparation la séparation nous en dire
un peu plus oui ce sont des histoires
courtes ou d'une nouvelle qui raconte
tout
une séparation due à une mutation
professionnelle à une maladie même à la
mort mais en même temps elle saisie chez
nouvelles ou 10
certes lâché par action elle est dure
elle est très difficile à vivre mais la
vie c'est un beau cadeau
elle vaut le coup d'être vécue voilà on
parle de séparation c'est pas forcément
c'est patrick serait ça parle quand même
du bonheur au final absolument absurde
et le bonheur de retrouver le goût et la
joie de vivre c'est ça surtout alors
pour vous présenter donc vous êtes menés
et vous avez grandi aux pays bas
exactement
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un peu
cette influence de la ba qui vous a fait
écrire oui les vendre littéraire la
marche beaucoup plus anglo-saxon
beaucoup plus des nouvelles et la
nouvelle
vous le savez certainement c'est le
sujet très brève c'est raconter
brièvement et ce qui est le plus
important c'est la chute
mais toute l'histoire est contenue en
quelques pages c'est pas comme elle est
comme un gros livre
et voilà ce qui nous permet moi d'écrire
ce que j'ai envie d'écrire ce que je
ressens justement vous parlez de la
chute
on sent un petit peu dans l'écriture cas
cette fois vous essayez de garder un
certain suspense jusqu'au bout
ah ça il faut il faut pas faux pas
dévoiler dès le départ il faut pas que
les lecteurs disent ah bah oui je sais
ce qui va se passer c'est non c'est pas
ça il faut garder un certain suspense et
parfois ce suspense oui il est
surprenant les on l'a déjà dit les gens
ils s'attendent pas à certaines chutes
surtout dans les livres de mercy bs oui
et alors commence à être venus à parler
de ce thème là la séparation comment
vous est venue l'idée d'écrire ce nouvel
c'est venu très spontanément jeu il ya
des choses qui se passe dans la tête
d'un écrivain ou c'est pas toujours
évident c'est pas toujours facile non
plus a expliqué pourquoi il ya quelque
chose qui se passe dans la tête voilà je
vais m'asseoir derrière mon ordinateur
bien sûr et je commence l'écriture je
n'ai pas toujours ça va me mener
parfois j'ai juste le début parfois j'ai
l'histoire entière mais qui reste à
développer bien sûr ce sont les
histoires fictives en pantalon rouge met
en avant elles sont toutes fictives il
n'y a rien de véhicules a du temps n'ont
aucune contrairement justement votre
premier roman qui était paru en 2009
ça s'appelait lamoura point d'âge y
étiez venu sur notre plateau on parlait
donc celui-ci est autobiographique il
parle d'amour en thèmes que l'on
retrouve souvent dans vos livres
il raconte en quelque sorte commence
autorisé le droit d'aimer au delà de 60
ans il a été traduit en anglais est paru
aux états unis
vous y étiez encore il ya quelques jours
absolument pas ce que vous racontez
comment ça s'est passé là bas aux états
unis la wii d'abord les livres lamoura
point d'âge et j'étais donc comme vous
dites j'étais déjà venu chez vous pour
le présenter une première fois et puis
il a été traduit en irlandais et c'est
mon nom des éditeurs aux pays bas qui
m'a proposé ensuite de les traduire aux
états unis est salée qui s'est occupé de
tout et voilà ça donnait times les loges
l'initiative lee revient mais moi j'ai
souscrit les deux mains bien entendu
donc vous l'avez dédicaces et là bas
j'ai un délicat celle ya bien ya quinze
jours le 22
même pas le 22 mars j'avais une première
dédicace là bas ça s'est très très bien
passé on s'est beaucoup amusé aussi
parce que tout se passe en anglais c'est
pas ça pas évident et on m'a promis
d'autres dédicace pour la fin de l'année
de cette année ou début 2015 d'accord
mais alors comment sa venue à le
traduire en fait c'est lg traduit parce
que machines et aux pays-bas vous
l'avais dit je trouvais que j'avais
envie de l'écrire et de fables de
l'oeuvre de le faire paraître également
opposés aux pays bas et je trouvais que
c'était bien en français et en
néerlandais ce qui était les néerlandais
c'est ma langue native et et puis mais
j'écris toujours en français et et puis
j'ai trouvé que c'était sympa de l'avant
dans les deux langues
je pensais pas du tout qui serait un
jour écrit en enfin traduit en anglais
est alors donc c'était votre premier
livre c'est un peu celui qui
beaucoup parlé beaucoup beaucoup nous
rappeler un petit peu l'histoire parce
que ça parle de vous c'est un mister
auto biographique affectivement celis
est une histoire d'amour j'ai dis
toujours c'est une histoire d'amour dans
une histoire d'amour c'est comme les
poupées russes vous en ouvriers vous en
trouver une autre
et puis voilà donc c'est une histoire
vue j'ai ressenti le besoin de l'écrire
et quand je les écris je l'ait soumis à
mon mari il m'a dit tu devrais le faire
publier
et voilà comment l'aventuré a démarré
et oui ils rencontrent du succès ici en
france vous reparler souvent d'amour
dans vos livres vous en avez écrit cinq
au total
oui on retrouve souvent quand même mais
l'amant si ce qui est pour moi le plus
important dans la vie n'est pas
seulement beau ya l'amour du couple
mais il ya aussi l'amour l'amour tout
court l'amour que je peux vous portez
vous en tant qu' ami en tant que membre
de ma famille je ne sais pas il ya
beaucoup de façons d'aimer et c'est très
important une arme dans la vie l'amour
c'est important l'amour qu'on porte aux
autres et quand on donne l'amour aux
autres on en reçoit aussi et vous parlez
aussi souvent de femmes ça emportant
sept heures et parce que les femmes
c'est très important
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui est un peu
différent dans ce dernier livre
voilà c'est moi cibler c'est possible et
c'est possible et femmes mais on a dit
que j'avais une écriture très féminine
ce qui fait que c'est plus les femmes
qui achètent ces livres là merci blaze
c'est plus les femmes qui l'achètent que
les hommes alors que l'amour apanage il
ya beaucoup d'hommes qu'ils achètent
aussi qu'est ce que vous entendez par
l'écriture très féminine qu'est-ce que
j'ai passé les leçons les lectrices qui
me le dise que j'ai à une plume féminine
donc je reprends ça et oui je pense que
j'aime ce style d'écriture et vous
comptez publié encore des histoires
coûté j'écris toujours dit j'ai écrites
depuis toujours j'ai créé toujours
maintenant je ne savais pas que j'allais
publiés merci blaise quand il est venu
chez vous la dernière fois voilà je peux
pas vous dire si ça va être publié et si
ça va être publié une date je peux rien
vous dire parce que voilà d'abord j'ai
j'ai un comité de lecture qui me dit si
oui ou non très bien intéressant vous
dites que vous écrivez depuis toujours
et alors qu'est ce qui fait qu'à un
moment donné vous avez décidé de de
publier deux seulement mari qui m'a
poussé moi je pensais pas être à la
traîne je pense que je pensais pas je
suis mis à écrire j'aime écrire je
pensais pas être capable de publier ou
d'être publié et puis c'est lui qui m'a
poussé j'ai trouvé un éditeur et puis
voilà j'en suis à mon cinquième c'est
une belle aventure
et puis au départ et on est une jeune
famille on a des enfants on n'a pas
vraiment le temps de s'occuper tout ça
et les moyens parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
les moyens je parle pas financier mais
les moyens numériques pour publier un
livre il ya 40 ans où il ya 30 ans
j'étais encore un parcours du combattant
pour accéder chez a pas approchés les
éditeurs alors qu'aujourd'hui avec
internet c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus
facile
ça m'a beaucoup aidée aussi
alors donc je rappelle votre dernier
ouvrage merci blaise vous le dédicacer
ce samedi 5 avril à 15 heures à la
librairie du pavé 17 mars
elle encourt le pavé dans la mare c'est
le pavé dans la mare d'accord au centre
commercial à elancourt oui voilà et on
pas se procurer remonte aux pavés aux
pavés là juste là bas mais les auditeurs
savent
voilà c'est toute façon il ya une autre
librairie un autre pavé ici à 50 ans
dans toutes les librairies du coin mais
là c'est vrai que le pavé dans la mare
schéma librairie à moindre coût que
voilà il a toujours mes livres en stock
tous et sinon les auditeurs seulement ça
me trouver sur internet très bien là
merci merci goldman devenu sur notre
plateau chez moi qui vous remercie
à bientôt à bientôt alors on parle
musique maintenant avec la 14e édition
de ce stage international de musique
ancienne et baroque du 20 au 28 avril
prochain à thoiry et ses environs le
festival brillamment baroque réuni
instrumentaliste confirmés ou débutants
ainsi que des chanteurs
orolia de l'uci a reçu la directrice de
cet événement elle nous donne quelques
précisions
au début c'est surtout les
instrumentistes et une chanteuse
nous avons malheureusement dû renoncer à
voir notre professeur de chant qui a eu
des ennuis de santé mais nous avons
quand même une stagiaire chanteuse et
donc ses professeurs et six stagiaires
vont se retrouver à l'école de thoiry
qui nous prête ses locaux pour
l'occasion c'est un stage à peu près
d'une semaine c'est un stage d'une
semaine
oui ça va commencer le dimanche c'était
un petit peu difficile à cause de la
place de pâques mais ça commence quand
même le dimanche après midi
et ça se déroule jusqu'au dimanche
suivant alors fait un stage qui
s'adresse à tous alors ça s'adresse à
des musiciens qui sont soit déjà
intéressé par la musique baroque depuis
longtemps et souhaitent perfectionner
leur pratique soit des musiciens qui ne
connaissent pas la pratique sur
instruments anciens et qui veulent la
découvrir et donc
on peut avoir aussi bien des gens d'un
niveau amateur que les gens d'un niveau
professionnel justement par parmi ceux
qui veulent changer de manière de
pratiquer leur instrument
dans tous les cas vous êtes
instrumentistes dans tous les cas il est
préférable d'être instrumentistes sinon
c'est assez frustrant alors c'est un
stage international puisque des élèves
venus et des professeurs absents
un peu partout en europe en l'occurrence
l'europe et même au delà
alors qui sont ces professeurs alors le
chef de file c'est un cubain qui a fait
ses études en europe qui habite en
europe depuis fort longtemps et qui à
l'origine était violoniste et s'est
perfectionnée en viole de gambe à un
moment où ça n'était pas du tout la mode
et qui a eu envie et la possibilité la
grande chance de pouvoir acquérir des
instruments anciens
non seulement pour lui mais aussi pour
pouvoir jouer avec ses amis est un grand
collectionneur il est devenu
collectionneur de fait parce que il a il
s'est intéressée à faire l'acquisition
d'instruments pour pouvoir jouer cette
musique avec ses amis avec ses élèves
puisqu'il est professeur et la
particularité c'est qu'ils prêtent
il est prête et même en cas d'une
stagiaire même à des stagiaires
débutants
si donc ils vont débuter sur vraiment d
instrument exceptionnel
il a dans sa collection par exemple des
violes de gambe qui sont l'équivalent
des violences de stradivarius et vous
avez des élèves débutants viol de vente
qui ont la chance de jouer sur ce genre
d'instrument s'est passé à ce
responsable
alors c'est josé wacquez on peut donc
josé vasquez donc principalement donc
jeu qui joue de la ville devant il a une
élève et comparses qui joue également de
la viole de gambe et du violoncelle
baroque
donc il va enseigner les deux lui va
enseigner aussi lu au maroc il y alors
elle les hongroises il y à une flûtiste
qui
et canadiennes mais qui habite en
allemagne et puis un claveciniste qui
est autrichien et donc habite viennent
et il y avait normalement une chanteuse
qui venait de république tchèque dont
vous voyez c'est assez assez varié en
culture toujours jeudi ce 10 avril le
théâtre de la chair à la verrière
propose une adaptation des mots forts et
bouleversant de wajdi mouawad dramaturge
et romancier libanais nicolas gervais a
rencontré la metteuse en scène catherine
cohen et le comédien grégori baquet
voici un extrait de l'acte et loire a
comme le chanteur mais tout le monde
m'appelle voir à et depuis peu je peux
dire le mot avant et c'est parfois une
catastrophe
ce qui m'intéresse c'est dans ce texte
c'est le thème de la résilience et le
passage de ce jeune homme qui va à
travers la mort de sa mère apprendre à
devenir adulte en recomposant tous les
morceaux de son histoire
c'est vraiment ce chemin initiatique de
ce garçon qui est en train de devenir
adulte et qui va et surtout passer par
le grand thème de tout être humain
d'ailleurs c'est comme ça qu'on peut
voir les êtres humains qui n'ont pas
grandi
pour certains c'est l'acceptation tout
simplement accepter de grandir accepté
devant les autres mourir accepté de
devenir un adulte a accepté de ne pas
avoir la vie forcément qu'on a qu'on a
voulu qu'on arrivait j'ai lu ce texte
et moi je me suis reconnu beaucoup
puisque c'est des choses que j'ai
moi-même vécu et je me suis dit j'ai
envie d'aborder ce texte avec un
personnage mais plus tard après qu'il
ait vécu tout ça comment il pourra nous
transmettre la sagesse de ce qu'il a
appris donc ça a été un point de vue de
mise en scène assez fort puisque
normalement de personnages à 19 ans et à
partir de ce moment là je pense à la
grecque puisque à chaque fois je pense à
un personnage de mon âge
dans lequel je projette énormément de
choses je pense à lui donc voila quand
votre mère meurt ça ne donne certes un
droit on ne vend bien en tirer un max
davantage
ça ébranle la touche où les 15 premières
amours et aux yeux des jambes devenu
porteur d'un destin particulier
je pense justement que je n'aurais pas
pu jouer ce texte si katherine ne
l'avait proposé il ya dix ans ou 12 ans
depuis justement depuis la comédie
musicale roméo juliette j'ai eu un grand
passage je suis passé par plein de
choses plein de théâtre différentes soit
des seuls en scène des pièces avec
beaucoup de personnages avec jean marie
bigard avec anny duperey avec geneviève
casile je passais par plein de gens
différents
maintenant je me sens prêt et d'ailleurs
je pense être prêt à jouer ce texte tout
seul l aborder ont en connaissance de
cause en tout cas en sachant où trouver
les émotions trouver les choses pour les
laisser toute la place aux textes mais
donc du coup aux comédiens donc c'était
très important pour moi d'avoir quelque
chose de très sobre et de travailler sur
l'accompagnement du comédien à travers
ce texte plutôt que
de lui plutôt que de l'envahir par
énormément de choses
[Musique]
direction maintenant voisins le
bretonneux camille tout est peintre et
sculpteur accueil sur deux week-ends
débutants et potiers amateurs pour un
stage de raku
dimanche dernier nous avons suivi la
première phase de cette technique
ancienne de poterie oralia debussy et
julien leroy c'est au petit atelier
d'art et de techniques artistiques plus
connu un voisins le bretonneux sous le
nom de l'atelier patata que se déroule
sur deux week-ends un stage de raku une
technique ancienne de cuisson de
poteries japonaise utilisés autrefois
lors de la cérémonie du thé on est
maillet et cuisez son vol avant de
l'utiliser
de nos jours cette technique est
pratiquée pour la réalisation de
diverses poterie et sculpture
ça permet d'obtenir des couleurs
flamboyantes et des effets particuliers
qu on obtiendrait peut-être pas de façon
aussi éclatante avec d'autres techniques
de céramique
alors ce qui est spécifique vraiment
c'est que on va on va faire éclater les
mailles de façon à ce que y est comme ça
tout un tir réseau qu'on trouve
décoratifs et on va mettre en valeur ce
petit réseau par un enfumage qui va
accentuer tout les craquelures il ya une
deuxième chose qu'on peut faire et qu'on
aime bien faire c'est qu'on obtient des
baux effet métallisé en utilisant
beaucoup d oxydes métalliques
c'est vraiment eu l'occasion de décider
d'ajouter de la couleur aux pièces parce
que les terres sortent en général rouge
ou blanche et donc on a on a envie de
donner la couleur par exemple là je suis
en train de faire un dragon donc j'ai
envie de qui sortent de lemaître bleu ou
vert je sais pas encore je vais
réfléchir mais qu'ils aient des belles
couleurs éclatantes
c'est tout à fait approprié à raku avec
l'effet de crack sûrs qu'ils pourraient
travailler sur les écailles et fabrique
voilà le terme raku provient d'un
idéogrammes qui signifie bonheur dans le
hasard car la méthode de cuisson très
partie
hier permet d'obtenir des résultats
variant à l'infini ce qui donne à la
pièce réaliser un caractère unique
ce qui est intéressant c'est de tout
côté aléatoire ça veut dire qu'on a
vraiment la surprise de de la sortie des
pièces du four à raku qui sont souvent
assez étonnante toujours très jolie voix
enfoncerait mais pas qu'il a déjà fait
quasiment un l'achat mode s'il y en
avait ouais on a parlé des marques
ça fait des petites marques yvon qui
vont partir au bout d'un moment ça va
sécher si tu trouves tu que tu n'as pas
ta main dakhla les étapes des maillages
de cuisson et d'enfumage sont prévues
les 17 et 18 mai prochain en attendant
qu'un millier ces stagiaires au film le
modelage de leur pièce à versailles une
centaine de personnes se sont réunis le
week-end dernier pour soutenir les
femmes handicapées sportifs de haut
niveau
un événement organisé pour la quatrième
année consécutive par la première ong
féminines mondiale inner wheel julien
leroy pour les images
monsieur d'hésitation pour sa quatrième
édition la marche a réuni une centaine
de personnes
un événement organisé par la première
ong féminines mondiale inner wheel
objectif aider les femmes handicapées
sportifs de haut niveau à progresser
dans leur discipline
c'est très important parce que ces
handicapés sportifs de haut niveau n'ont
pas tellement de de revenus entre
guillemets donc par cette marche qui est
national
donc toutes les tous les clubs inner
wheel de france maroc tunisie et et
andorre qu'elles sont rattachés
également fond cette marche aujourd'hui
dans tout dans tous les départements
c'est une marche nationale
parmi les participants des femmes bien
sûr mais aussi des sommes investies pour
cette cause féminine
ils ont parcouru plus de 6 km autour du
grand canal de versailles
c'est un moment de
deux rencontres c'est un moment des
espaces en plus avec la météo
d'aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement agréable
c'est pas l'audit ou passer d'habitude
le faisons en footing donc c'était très
agréable on échange un moment très
privilégié
fondé il ya 90 ans le club inner wheel
encore peu connus se définit comme la
roue intérieure du rotary club
ses origines remontent à la fin de la
première guerre mondiale les épouses de
rotariens de grande bretagne et
d'irlande continuer à se réunir en y
invitant les veuves et les filles
célibataires des rotariens disparu
pour sa septième édition l'eco-trail de
paris partait une nouvelle fois de la
base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
plus de 1500 trailer ont dévalé les 80
km de l'épreuve
toujours aussi respectueuse de
l'environnement un reportage d' anthony
rech après cinq heures 40 de course
l'expérimenté manuel gosses impôts sur
l'eco trail de paris 2014 version 80 km
est toujours aussi beau varier plaisant
difficile aussi un jeu je le répèterai
jamais assez mais c'est une course
magnifique mais je peux vous dire que ça
sort vraiment dur dur six heures plus
tôt les 1579 participants se préparent
dans le sas de départ un effort d'une
extrême intensité
si certains découvrent le parcours
parisien d'autres trailer habitués ne
louperait pour rien au monde l'eco-trail
et mythique avec des très très très
jolie portion se montait de santé
essentiellement faite de relance
et la cerise sur le gâteau c'est
d'arriver la plupart s'entraîne
exclusivement pour cette course depuis
plusieurs mois par dose d'une centaine
de kilomètres par semaine sur une
distance aussi longue
le trailer doit surtout gérer son
alimentation mais aucun papier par terre
sur le parcours
à chacun sa touche écolo c'est surtout
ça l'eco-trail s'il ya un truc qui
m'agace c'est les papiers par terre les
petites doses est par terre mois
s'annoncent à il faut pas ouais vraiment
ça c'est un truc super importants en
montagne c'est pareil on passe tout
c'est indissociable indissociables
lorquin montrer leur sens son petit sac
de récupération de
deux sachets plastiques ça n'existe pas
au bout donc de 5h40 de foule et
emmanuel gault a remporté en solitaire
ce septième eco trail de paris sous la
tour eiffel
les cougars de montigny peaufinent les
derniers réglages avant la reprise de la
saison de la division 2 le joueur
historique du club alexandre couton a
pris la succession d'arnaud faut au
coaching pour débuter un nouveau cycle
anthony rech et jonathan wilmet il
comptait faire une pause et s'est
éloigné des terrains mais finalement à
32 ans alexandre coûte on découvre le
costume d'entraîneur joueurs des cougars
depuis 1998 le shore stop deuxième base
a accepté fin janvier de prendre la
succession d'arnaud faut pour rendre
service au club mais pas question de
faire du cumul de mandats le fait de
revenir en tant que coach je veux
vraiment faire les choses bien et je
sais que c'est pas facile de pouvoir
faire les deux en même temps donc je
préfère d'abord me concentrer sur le
coaching et puis on a largement de quoi
faire dans l'équipe pour sa première
saison sur un banc seniors alex coûte on
pourra se reposer sur le retour
d'anciens joueurs comme sébastien
duchaussoy ou encore hausse les coupes
man le nouvel entraîneur et nous
montrent un compte bien utiliser la
génération dorée des juniors qui ont
frôlé le titre de champion de france la
saison passée
des renforts qui pourraient permettre
aux cougars de faire mieux qu'en 2013
lésigny monte avait terminé en tête de
la phase régulière mais ils étaient
passés à côté de leur demi-finale dans
un premier temps les play-offs
et puis après on va prendre match par
match
on n'a pas d'objectif on va dire à court
terme de monter pour l'instant c'est
après ont fini premiers bains le club
devait on veut rejouer en élite mais il
faut qu'on est l'équipe faire bonne
figure dans la première division
éléments de réponse lors de la première
journée sur le terrain du promu rennais
on termine cette édition avec votre
agenda du week end
ce samedi 5 avril à magny les hameaux
des stands de sur les éco-gestes à la
maison vous seront proposées une
activité qui s'inscrit dans le cadre de
l'opération nettoyage de printemps
rendez vous sur le parvis de l'hôtel de
ville dès 13h30 une autre date également
ça se passe tout le week-end de la 6è
édition de l'expo bd présente les 20 ans
de la collection signée des éditions le
lombard
l'exposition propose notamment plus de
100 dessins originaux et un documentaire
audiovisuel un grand nombre de
dessinateurs de cette collection seront
également présentes pour des dédicaces
de 14 heures à 18 heures dans les salons
de l'hôtel de ville de versailles
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité dès lundi à 18h pour le 7 8
la q1 d'ici là je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end sur théophile
[Musique]